pas jouer à ce coup teboul secoue teboul
c'est un jeu exceptionnel
chaque chroniqueur va avoir deux
bouteilles une bouteille d'ailleurs une
bouteille dans chaque main dans lesquels
il y aura des mais il faut secouer les
bouteilles pour faire passer les be d'un
côté d'une autre bouteille d'accord vous
allez voir je vous montrais de suite
vous allez vous affrontez trois par
trois celui qui aura fini en premier
sera qualifié y aura donc trois groupes
de trois puisque vous êtes 9 à la fin il
y aura une finale à 3 de l'accord est le
grand gagnant m'affronte rats bien
entendu super finale jeudi
alors chez vous pouvez jouer sur le
compte twitter de tp pronostiqué le
chroniqueur qui arrivera au final pour
tenter gagner une super de consoles de
jeu quand je vous dis que c'est la
console c'est la console ses yeux
console peut pas avoir une petit visuel
la de la console il y aura une autre
console en jeu si celui qui joue en
finale contre moi gagne et remportera la
console si c'est moi qui gagne je ferais
gagner la console à une personne du
public voilà ici il ya des boules avec
toutes les personnes du public d'accord
mais chéri on va commencer avec le
premier groupe
le premier groupe qui sera composé de
jean michel baylet him as et kelly ok
c'est parti on ne prenait chacun et
votre bouteille
attention vous avez compris de jéhovah
vrai nom de bull dans chaque semaine
langue de boules
vous mettez bien alignés c'est très
simple à mon top vous retourner et vous
essayez de faire passer les pays dans
l'autre bouteille le plus rapidement
possible dans ce coin là bas mon
attention 3,2 à top
[Applaudissements]
oui
besset ces journées saint jean
[Applaudissements]
les gens lui qui est au final nous avons
mis excellent c'est que j'adore ce jeu
je peux le cas à 8h10 énervante ma
tension alors je vous le dis deuxième
demi-finale entre eric naulleau s'ils
savaient qu'ils versent un jour celui-ci
n'a pas le rythme l'eau gilles et
isabelle vous n'aimez pas besoin de
bouger puisque je suis allé y mettez
vous bien bien face à face est non mais
t'es mettez vous la mettez vous sur les
caméras mais plus content d'être donc
fait de la télé bien doc normal
attention 3-2 attaque
[Applaudissements]
à la casse et la bouteille
stop alors isabelle éliminé bien lent
qu'on lui connaît la 4c la bouteille
dont vous êtes éliminé de douala et à la
mairie de qualité heureusement on a la
une de leur science on n'a même pas du
tout alors
à qui ça il faut les avoir tous cas
isabelle voilà on fait attention
maintenant les trois derniers demi
finalistes
raymond gilles e damrémont géraldine et
benjamin allait jamais elle ne fait pas
quoi te casser pas les bouteilles le
kung fu l'abaya le pupitre là vous voyez
bien deux autres mettez-vous devant
mettez-vous de mon équipe j'ai
l'impression d'être à l'école sont les
voisins
je vous jure l'impression d'être à
l'école avec une classe difficile at on
besoin d'eux at home
vraiment trop mignonne vraiment
améliorer mes envies bilatéraux mieux
[Musique]
demandez aux trois finalistes de venir
me rejoindre à dire jean michel benjamin
et eric naulleau c'est plus visible
[Applaudissements]
attention un bail à cela il faut dire
vous voulez attention c'est parti
tiens tiens tiens attention 3
2 un top
[Applaudissements]
allez
sacrément l'heure quand même en afrique
et vous surprend la javie benjamin tu
sois dis toi que tu veux non non je
voulais choix des armes vas-y fais ce
que tu veux retenir l'attention sur leur
cas oui siens 3 2 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
c'est étonnant
c'est très gênant quand même donc ceux
qui ont voté pour castaldi sais pas qui
c'est bien d'une console dans le public
le numéro gagnent une console de jeux
[Musique]
on peut lui donner
est il est patente sur twitter une des
personnes parmi des étudiants ont voté
pour benjamin castaldi gagne également
étudié mieux ça ton amer sa merci